a little word association time as we go
week in review
what what what word or words come to
mind that aren't profane
that uh peter you may think of when you
see what van noy had to say about flores
i
i think that look i think brian flores
uh has had a great impact uh on the
dolphins franchise and was an excellent
selection as coach
but
i mean he's had about 16 offensive
coordinators there so far they can't get
that right
and
he
knew kyle van noy exceedingly well
so well that for the first year that
kyle van noy played in miami the miami
dolphins paid him 15
million dollars
and they got 14 games for that and then
they they cut him
so i mean to me
you know there something happened there
and
someday when brian flores writes his
book we'll probably get his version of
what happened because he totally keeps
cards close to the vest
but my feeling right now about that is
that look brian flores and to a lesser
degree chris greer
they got to do better in personnel and
coach selection that's my reaction to
all this
they they you can't you can't give
a a huge free agent
15 million dollars in one year then just
cut them you can't do that very often
anyway
and i think it's a cautionary tale for
miami
i also think from my perspective you
know what i thought of was no sacred
cows and that's kind of the approach
that bill belichick had and that's what
flores learned
over all those years he was in new
england you make your decisions
independent and irrespective
of what a guy has done in the past what
you've paid him in the past whether you
like him or don't you have to make your
decisions based on a cold rational
assessment of where your team is and
where you want your team to go even if
it means making some dramatic changes
flores isn't afraid to do that daniel
snyder is going to buy out his minority
partners fred smith robert rothman
dwight schar had been trying for well
over a year
to sell their interest they had found a
buyer for their total interest
snyder wanted to just piecemeal
exercises right of first refusal that
sparked arbitration litigation finally
snyder on the brink of getting
permission from the league to exceed the
debt ceiling so he can
buy them out what is the first word or
group of words that may come to mind
when you see that snyder is going to
have 100 of the washington football team
it's bad news for the fans of a fabled
franchise
i don't see
i don't see how daniel snyder owning
this team is good for people who love
the burgundy in gold
and look
he can do whatever he wants
he owns the franchise the nfl has shown
time and again
that barring
a horrendous situation which
i'm not sure how
what percentage
you know all of this stuff off the field
with the cheerleaders and and all that i
don't know that's some percentage of
horrendous okay but i guess it doesn't
rise to horrendous enough to make you
sell your team
but you look at the history of of this
franchise under daniel snyder it stinks
and you know if you're a fan of this
franchise it's a sad week
my first reaction was no forced sale
that's what i thought when i saw that
this was being done the league's not
going to do this guy any favors he's not
going to make it any easier for him to
consolidate 100 of the equity in the
team if they're getting ready to tell
him that his punishment
for years of workplace misconduct that
occurred on his watch would be that he's
going to be mandated to sell the team to
someone else they just wouldn't have
done it and that's been the reaction
that others in
positions of power and influence around
the league have had as well it wouldn't
be getting to this point if the league
was thinking about saying to daniel
snyder you must sell the team and you
know what peter i will say one thing him
getting the extra 40 really doesn't
matter as it relates to the control of
the team one of the reasons it's only i
say only because the team is worth more
than this when you break it down on a
percentage basis 950 875 million
somewhere in that ballpark for 40
percent that's a valuation of between
2.3 2.4 billion
but that minority interest isn't worth
as much because you don't have power you
don't have voting rights you don't have
a path to control
so snyder already held that so this
doesn't matter this just means he owns
it all people just assumed he owns it
all now he will own it all and at some
point he'd be able to sell it all if he
wants to but my understanding has always
been he wants to give it to his kids and
now he'll give them the whole team not
just a piece of it
i wonder if he if if uh if he'll give
his kids the right to pick the next
wayne haskins
i mean well this is this is just not a
it's it's just not good news for the
future of football in washington it just
isn't and i'm not saying any of these
other owners are miracle workers i mean
cal mcnair is doing one heck of a job in
houston uh you know so i i don't know
mike it's just when i saw that this week
i shrugged my shoulders and i just said
bad news for fans of that franchise
good news is they've shown some things
as you stack them up that that give us
reason to believe that a brighter day
may be coming but we'll wait and see how
that plays out brighter days obviously
in tampa bay we talked about
the possibility of larry fitzgerald
earlier but let's focus for now on the
fact that six of their eight free agents
are back when we saw this week that
dominican sioux is joining that list of
guys who will be staying put what was
your reaction
uh
you know half of my reaction is good you
know they
the band will be back together
and really with the exception
right now the biggest one i think is
antonio brown he scored a touchdown in
the super bowl brady really trusts him
and all that but
you know they've got basically everybody
back and i guess my only issue is
you know bill parcells had a famous
saying that he would say
four times a day if he said it once
which is you never pick up one year
where you left off the previous year
and so look i think the bucks are should
be favorites to win it again i get it
but i guess my whole point
you know about where they are right now
is that
you know this still guarantees you
nothing and even getting oj howard back
it all guarantees you nothing this is a
very very good team an excellent
football team
uh and and i think it's great that they
have all these guys back but
football's a funny game
the ball is shaped in a very in in an
over ball is shaped like an oval
and you know it takes funny bounces
and who knows if what happens if kevin
king
doesn't play an awful game and by the
way
how about kevin king getting six million
dollars to resign with green bay like
did anybody there watch football games
last year
especially in the postseason
i mean
what the heck was that
anyway i mike i think it's good that
they're bringing these guys back but
does it ensure anything absolutely not
the
uh
points bat folks have been impressed by
what the buccaneers have done the odds
have improved dramatically for the
buccaneers to repeat the chiefs are
still the betting favorite according to
points bat but but the buccaneers have
have managed to hold it together enough
that they are regarded as one of the
shortlist favorites now from plus 1200
down to plus 525
plus 1200 right after winning it
in early february and now the odds
dramatically better for the bucks but
we'll see and look we hey there's a
reason why teams don't repeat very often
there's a reason why it's just been the
patriots over the past 20 years and
before that we had the broncos two in a
row we had the cowboys two in a row but
it hasn't happened very often since free
agency came along and that's one of the
big reasons why so uh having tom brady
makes a huge difference we'll see if
that can make the difference in 2021
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports